[Music]  let's talk about classic Chrome  [Music]  recently I made two new Sony film  simulations one is a replica after the  Fujifilm classic Chrome film simulation  and the other one is the picture profile  made after the original Kodachrome 64  film stock and in this video I'll  explain in detail the main  characteristics and differences between  the Fujifilm and the Sony classic Chrome  let me know in the comments if you want  to find out more about the Kodachrome 64  film simulation it'll make another video  about it before we start remember all  Sony film simulation recipes can be  found on my website let's start with the  classic Chrome  this Sony picture profile was made after  the Fujifilm simulation and I used the  Fuji axis stand compared to two sample  Clips as you can see they look very  similar with some slight differences  they are identical in terms of contrast  Fuji seems to have a better dynamic